with the collection how much room was
there to do another tape or some of
these scenes just one take only and just
had to get it right or was there some
room to play a little bit Liz thorsson
know there was definitely room to play I
mean it was so physical that you knew
that there were going to be shot from so
many different angles from and with so
many different takes just to make the
scope of that possible so you knew that
you were going to have all the
opportunity that you wanted or needed to
get what you wanted and to explore what
you wanted you know obviously if we're
going to burn the joint down we you know
we can only burn it so much so we have
to you know we have to get it yeah no I
mean same I feel like I feel like we had
especially Marcus pays a lot of
attention to the character line into
character development so it's a very
action-packed film but there was a lot
of opportunity to I mean those moments
were important and you knew that they
were in and he gave enough time to that
you the director gave enough time to to
the emotional life of what the
characters are going through so as a
gift in that sense I guess
you